he attacks black athletes as he did
starting with his rally in Alabama
continued on Twitter and he attacks them
for protesting peacefully for equality
for standing up for what they believe
and he does it once again to dog-whistle
to his base and to try to detract
attention from other things that are
going on but it's quite telling that he
is willing to attack black athletes he
never said a thing about race isn't this
about respect for the anthem the flag
and the men and women in military that
fought and died
let me say first of all Hillary Clinton
is a racist demagogue I mean let's be
blunt let's be straight out about this
thing she can't possibly debate on the
merits any of the things we're talking
about this racial they didn't mean her
she's racist he met racial demagogue I
mean I mean she is using racism as a
deliberate weapon she is dividing the
country on racial grounds as a
deliberate political weapon in exactly
the model of modern liberalism which
can't possibly survive if they don't
constantly go back to racism now talking
about their racism Donald Trump said
nothing that had anything to do about
race he talked about defending the flag
he talked about defending you know our
national anthem now
how you take that and translate it into
a racial attack tells you everything you
need to know about the sickness of the
modern left and the sickness of
Democratic Party they cannot survive if
they can't constantly yell race and as a
result they have become one of the most
divisive what does she do forces in
America today what it where's it sent
well Americans say I'm a Saturday for
look I think the American people the
American people have to have an honest
open conversation and I think let's go
back to the idea of First Amendment
rights I am
totally for the rights of every athlete
in America on their own time - I don't
say anything I want to I'm totally for
they're taking their multi-million
dollar salary the feeling of spending on
the left-wing causes go do it if they
want to go take this spare time and go
to left-wing rallies go do it what I am
NOT for is them deciding that they'll
take an event the you and I tuned into
because we thought it was a neutral
sporting event yeah this is the
operative the spirit of sports well it
defies everything about why we love
sports and it's truly sad to see
politics do this to our political system
all right mr. speaker your online course
it's a link to my website Hannity calm
understanding Trump number one on the
bestseller list 12 weeks and running on
the list